bonsoir nouvelle édition du journal de
la rédaction nous sommes le 13 avril
nous allons faire ensemble le tour de
l'actualité locale et aujourd'hui il
sera notamment question du déplacement
d'emmanuel coste la ministre du logement
qui était à la verrières hier soir pour
découvrir les projets de la commune une
visite de terrain pour mieux apprécier
les difficultés rencontrées au quotidien
les associations et centres de soins
vont recevoir des tests rapides de
dépistage pour détecter le virus de
l'hépatite c sur un modèle similaire à
ceux destinés au sida ils permettront
d'améliorer la prise en charge des
dizaines de milliers de personnes qui
ignorent leur infection à clairefontaine
au goût du jour pour recevoir l'équipe
de france de football en vue de l'euro
2016 le camp de base des bleus a connu
quelques évolutions visite guidée au
cours de ce journal
emmanuelle cosse ministre du logement
était donc hier soir à la verrière
invités par la municipalité la ministre
s'est rendue sur les deux sites qui sont
concernés par des projets immobiliers la
zone d'aménagement concerté dit gare
bécane et un habitat participatif son
objectif mesurer au mieux la réalité du
terrain dans une petite commune mélanie
poquet a suivi ce déplacement bailleurs
sociaux acteurs immobiliers et
conseillers municipaux de la verrière
ils étaient tous réunis autour de la
ministre du logement emmanuelle cosse et
lui ont présenté les projets
d'habitation de la commune on voit bien
que sur les questions de financement sur
les questions de montage juridique il ya
encore un travail à faire il ya des
choses qui ont été faites qui améliore
mais il ya encore un travail donc les
investisseurs les promoteurs sont
présents sur le territoire de la
dernière ont pu poser effectivement à la
ministre ces questions pour faciliter
les montages dans ses projets un habitat
participatif rue de la mare 14 logements
devraient voir le jour à cet emplacement
mais le gros projet sait la zac la zone
d'aménagement concerté de gars bécane
des habitations mais aussi un pôle
d'activité de plus de 80 mille mètres
carrés oui c'est important d'aller
soutenir les collectivités qui
s'engagent sur eux sur ces questions là
parce que quand vous êtes maire d'une
commune de 6000 habitants que vous
envisagez de construire
1000 1500 logements c'est une évolution
considérable
il ya aussi un enjeu d'activités
économiques sont très important de le
rappeler qui est qu' il faut qu'on
rapproche l'activité économique les
logements parce qu'on sait que
typiquement notamment pour les habitants
des yvelines
beaucoup d'entre eux travaillent sur
l'arrêt sur le centre de paris ou à la
défense et qu'on a des plans de
transport extrêmement difficiles avec
les 1800 logements prévus sur la zac la
verrière deviendra une commune de près
de 10000 habitants
les travaux devraient débuter en 2017 il
y aura bien une nouvelle élection pour
désigner président et vice président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines le tribunal administratif a
décidé d'annuler le précédent scrutin du
9 janvier dernier expliquant que les
conditions d'accès au public n'avait pas
été respectée la majorité de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines majorité de
droite a décidé de ne pas faire appel
elle évoque des polémiques politiciennes
et souhaite un apaisement
alors nous avons décidé de ne pas faire
appel par rapport à 6 on tue des
magistrats dit même si je la conteste et
même si aujourd'hui les éléments de mes
avocats nous donner toutes les raisons
de pouvoir gagner en conseil d'état
simplement ça va encore faire six mois
de retard et recourent beaucoup d'argent
dépensé pour moi cette nouvelle élection
est un non-événement donc je
représenterai exactement les mêmes
délibération que j'avais présenté au
mois de janvier on c'est à dire que
toutes les communes de gauche seront
représentés dont le bureau par contre il
n'y aura pas de délégation offerte à la
gauche nuit debout fait des émules dans
les yvelines à mantes-la-jolie vendredi
soir un collectif de citoyens en temps à
son tour mettre en place ce qui est
défini comme un espace de rencontre de
dialogue et des changes
leur rendez vous si vous êtes à mantes
la jolie est fixé place paul baert c'est
à 19h35 vendre ce vendredi donc on parle
santé à présent et c'est une première en
france l'association hf prévention vient
de présenter le premier test rapide
d'orientation et de dépistage du virus
de l'hépatite le principe est similaire
à celui de l'auto test du dépistage
dépistage vih
médecins infirmiers ou encore
associations vont pouvoir l'utiliser dès
le mois de mai
hamel pour les précisions il était très
attendu par les milieux associatifs
le premier test rapide d'orientation et
de diagnostic du virus de l'hépatite c a
été présenté à la presse le 12 avril
l'objectif de cet outil élargir et
renforcer le dépistage d'une maladie
souvent méconnue est sous-estimée par
les français le principe c'est tout
simple c'est à partir d'une goutte de
sang au bout du doigt 30 micro lite donc
une toute petite quantité de sang et
bien qu'on va déposer sur ce test est au
bout de 15 minutes
la personne aura le résultat de son test
de dépistage de l'hépatite c
un test disponible à partir du mois de
mai pour les professionnels et les
associations en france ce sont environ
80000 personnes infectées qui ignorent
leur statut
on a des données qui datent de 2004 où
on a montré que la prévalence la
fréquence de l'hépatite c cédé 0,85 % et
dont tu eu deux tiers était est et avait
avec du virus dans le sang donc on
pensait aller à l'époque il y avait à
peu près de 230 mille sujets infectés
ce chiffre a diminué puisque on a traité
des patients de temps on a on sait que
ça diminue les populations dites à
risques qui sont les plus exposés
l'usagé de drogues personnes transfusées
avant 1992 ou par contamination sexuelle
exceptionnel dans certaines populations
aujourd'hui effectivement on va vers les
publics les plus à risque et on
proposera en même temps qu'on propose du
vih on proposera donc une offre vhc ce
qui va permettre donc aux gens de
pouvoir avoir un vrai dépistage beaucoup
plus complet que ce qu'on proposait
jusqu'à présent l'avantagent du trod
c'est que ça se passe rapidement et puis
effectivement on va pouvoir aller vers
ces populations c'est la spécialité
d'achève prévention et effectivement on
est en train de cibler des régions
notamment l'ile-de-france où il ya
énormément de personnes contaminées vhc
mais aussi paca languedoc et
nord-pas-de-calais où on avait donc déjà
une forte incidence sur le vih durant la
conférence l'association sos hépatites a
pointé du doigt le fonctionnement du
ministère de la santé
aujourd'hui les écoutes traitement
son important puisqu'on considère
caressa un traitement c'est à peu près
40 mille euros pour autant les coûts
étant important le ministère a décidé de
soigner d'abord les personnes avec des
hépatites graves
donc on est à deux sirops une pression
le plus gros du boulot est fait et
aujourd'hui il reste des gens avec des
hépatites minimes qui n'ont pas accès
aux traitements il va falloir revoir les
coûts des traitements et l'accès aux
traitements pour tout le monde pour
l'association une solution existe grâce
à des médicaments génériques venus de
l'étranger mais non remboursés par la
sécurité sociale
ce mardi après-midi la direction des
services départementaux de l'éducation
nationale vient d'organiser donc une
journée dédiée à l'initiation au tennis
plus de 330 élèves yvelinois ont pu
tester leur revers et leur coup droit
c'était au tennis-club de guyancourt
un reportage de michael almy d'or
associer le tennis et la scolarité c'est
l'objectif des rencontres
départementales organisées par
l'éducation nationale pour cette
septième édition plus de 330 élèves de
primaire venus de quinze classes ont
frappé la balle ce mardi au tennis-club
de guyancourt c'est une fois par an mais
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que les
élèves sont initiés dans leur école et
qu'il y as entre les écoles elles mêmes
déjà des tournois des confrontations
cette manifestation cède aujourd'hui à
une plus grande ampleur parce qu'elle
est au niveau départemental et elle
consacre encore une fois tout le travail
qui a pu être fait en amont dans les
écoles quatre ateliers étaient au
programme pour travailler les
déplacements la coordination et la
précision avec la raquette il prenait la
balle ans
on l'a visée en phase avec la main on
faisait tous fait quoi on échange et là
ballons là on l'a envoyée tu trouves que
c'est joli d'ici là pourquoi tu dis ça
parce que c'est facile à rattraper la
balle ben j'aime bien qu'on se fasse des
échanges je vais tirer dans la bad
après quatre heures de jeu les élèves
ont reçu des récompenses de la part des
éducateurs
y a pas de classement beaucoup m'ont
demandé pourquoi mais nous on n'est pas
sur le classement n'est sûr le plaisir
partagé tout au long de la journée et
donc ils ont eu des casquettes avec
marquez en souvenir de la rencontre
départementale tennis qui leur a été
offert par du cercle il
ils on est dégoûtés donc un faux
reprendre des forces après une telle
rencontre
ils ont eu des balles qui ont été
offerts par le club une huitième édition
des rencontres départementales devraient
être programmées en avril 2010 est la
ville qui accueillera les épreuves n'est
pas encore connue sport toujours on
prend la direction à présent de
voisins-le-bretonneux ou la judokate
jeff bridges première championne du
monde de l'histoire de la discipline
dans la catégorie des moins de 48 kg à
new york en 1980 étaient présentes à
était donc dans la ville
saint-quentinoise la sportive a présenté
au centre sportif des pyramides ses
astuces et techniques au cours d'un
stage une quarantaine de judokas étaient
présentes sur les tatamis pour suivre ce
cours
l'athlète est au micro de michael et
demi d'euros ça me fait toujours plaisir
que les gens soient là qu'ils sont
heureux d'être là et d'apprendre et de
travailler ensemble on va faire du
travail technique une partie savez au
sol en judo il ya différentes parties
donc au sol on va commencer et ensuite
on va
travailler debout des techniques debout
et quelques petits combats à la fin on
ne parlera pas de l'élimination du paris
saint-germain en champion's league mais
nous allons à présent bien parler de
football le centre d'entraînement de
l'équipe de france situé à
clairefontaine dans les yvelines a été
rénové en vue de l'euro 2016 la
compétition va se dérouler du 10 juin au
10 juillet en france et pour que les
bleus soient dans les meilleures
conditions
salle de musculation tu es un centre
médical et espaces médias ont été
restaurés moderniser reportage michael
et demi d'euros images de williams elle
à nouveau clairefontaine pour les bleus
à deux mois du début de l'euro 2016 un
bâtiment de 5000 de son mètre carré a
été inaugurée ce vendredi 8 avril en
présence du secrétaire d'état chargé des
sports thierry braillard et du président
de la fédération française de football
noël le graet la structure abritera
notamment le centre de formation et de
conférences en parallèle les terrains
les espaces de musculation et le centre
médical ont été modernisées pour l'euro
pour les joueurs c'est qu'ils viennent
s'entraîner il faut qu'ils aient d'une
qualité terrain aussi bonne que dans les
grands clubs et les joueurs de haut
niveau donc aujourd'hui l'effort à café
sur tous les terrains ils ont
l'infectiologue qualitatif donc ça c'est
important au dessus du niveau médical on
est bien équipé au niveau technique de
récupération on est passé dans l'équipe
et je pense qu'on est au niveau de
satisfaction pour des joueurs de haut
niveau pour rénover ce site de 56
hectares ouverts depuis 1988 6 millions
d'euros ont été investis sur trois ans
les joueurs de l'équipe de france ont
glissé des idées pour améliorer les
équipements il ya des échanges bien
évidemment par rapport aux besoins qui
peuvent avoir et après c'est en
discussion aussi avec avec mon staff
staff technique et staff médical et
après évidemment c'est toujours validé
par la fédération hde par rapport au
coût des travaux mais y en a toujours eu
des personnels écoute pour nous faire en
sorte de nous mettre dans les meilleures
conditions
l'euro débutera en france ce 10 juin
prochain les tricolores devraient
s'installer dans leur camp de base à
partir du 5 juin et avant l'euro ce sont
les prochaines vacances qui approchent
les examens a aussi l'association
archimède à voisins le bretonneux
propose des cours de soutien de révision
pour le brevet pour le bac
les renseignements qui s'affiche et à
prendre directement auprès des
responsables donc à l'adresse mail qui
s'est affichée vous le voyez
environnement a présenté une nouvelle
semaine dédiée à cette cause qui se met
en place à trappes depuis aujourd'hui et
jusqu'au 20 avril des ateliers des
expositions sont proposées
ainsi cet après midi à la salle jean
baptiste clément le public le plus
souvent familiales étaient conviés
écoutez thomas sûrs dix élus en charge
de l'urbanisme de l'environnement
de la qualité de vie il nous parle des
différents temps forts de cet événement
il ya trois ans exactement trois temps
important olemps sous forme d'ateliers
cet après midi donc ce mercredi 13 avril
de 14 heures à 17 heures des ateliers
des jeux tout public
le deuxième temps c'est qu'effectivement
on va voir des habitants notamment le
lundi 18 avril directement en lien avec
les centres sociaux et puis des
bailleurs aux pieds les immeubles des
ateliers notamment de récupération d'eau
de pour le jardin et partie famille on
va voir des actions de sensibilisation
sur le tri la propreté permettre aussi
de découvrir la nature et la nature l on
n'en parle pas assez
le troisième temps fort finalement c'est
le mercredi 20 avril donc il va clôturer
cette semaine de l'environnement qu'on a
voulu à cheval entre 1 à 2 hors vacances
scolaires de main contre l'eire on ne
puisse pas le même public mais elle aura
donc son point d'orgue le mercredi 20
avril à l'auditorium de l'école de
musique et de danse avec la clôture de
la semaine de l'environnement et fait
bien évidemment une séance ouverte aux
habitants ne laisserai jamais trompé
loisirs les participants s'est ouvert à
tous et on navigue bien évidemment le
plus grand nombre à venir se renseigner
au plus près environnement toujours et
comme tous les mercredis on passe
maintenant à la chronique avec mélanie
poquet bonsoir mélanie cette semaine il
sera question de propreté dans la nature
avec ce concept randonnée et la rando
net porte bien son nom puisqu'elle a
pour but de nettoyer la nature et la
forêt c'est caudéran 2,78 le comité
départemental de randonnée pédestre des
yvelines qui a été approché par des
randonneurs qui trouvait vraiment la
forêt très sale cela ça leur a donné
l'idée de mettre en place les randos net
écoute et jacqueline marinoni
elle est secrétaire général du comité la
philosophie du randonneur et que nous ne
laissons aucun déchet derrière nous on
voudrait transmettre au public cette
philosophie et les invités à ne rien
jeter eu non plus ou à prendre
l'habitude de ramasser quand il amène
quelque chose dans la nature et
remporter les contenants avec eux parce
qu'on trouve les bouteilles le verre des
canettes des sachets en plastique enfin
il ya c'est assez volumineux quand même
ce qu'on trouvait assez étonnant
c'est étonnant ses volumineux on a une
idée de ce que ça représente à peu près
alors pour vous rendre compte les
randonneurs ont été lancés en novembre
nous avions à l'époque suivi
l'association loisirs et sports
d'elancourt elle est adhérente à
caudéran de 78 il avait ramassé plus de
400 litres de déchets sur seulement 12
km que comptait leur randonnée
un autre exemple puisque chaque année au
mois d'avril de nombreux nettoyages de
printemps sont organisées sur les
communes notamment celle du parc naturel
de la haute vallée de chevreuse l'an
dernier c'était la commune de magny les
hameaux qui avait eu le droit il avait
ramassé plus de 2000 litres de déchets
c'est une jolie initiative et on peut la
saluer bien évidemment même s'il
faudrait mieux faire attention à la
nature et pas jeter tout n'importe où
mais que deviennent ces déchets après
alors les participants les randonneurs
ramène le sac de ramassage qu'ils ont
chez eux
on va le voir à l'image c'est un sac qui
a une capacité de dix litres ils vont
les trier ce qui ne peut pas être triés
sera après ramener en déchetterie il y a
les clubs
on le disait mais aussi des communes il
viennoise qui ont été sensibles à ce
mouvement et caudéran de 78 est
notamment soutenu par l'eau nf et le
département au nfc est un soutien
surtout morale mais on a des conventions
spécifiques entre la randonnée et les
vnf
donc on a rêvé de travailler ensemble
donc voilà on il passe de notre
information sur leur site
et puis le conseil départemental à
partir du moment où c'est une action qui
est tourné vers le grand public va nous
aider aussi
j'espère en tout cas plus que moralement
allez pour participer lors donner un
coup de main il faut se rapprocher des
clubs qui sont affiliés à caudéran d'eau
le comité les appels à proposer
eux-mêmes les propres rangs d'onet ça se
passe sur tout le mois d'avril il décide
exactement le jour où ils veulent le
faire
on peut les retrouver sur le site de
condé rocco des randos il faut savoir
qu'il ya 48 clubs qui sont associés au
comité 42 accueil du public est il pour
le moment il y en a 24 qui participent à
ces nettoyages ces rendez-vous sont
amenés à être renouvelé tous les ans
toujours au mois d'avril et peut-être un
jour wilfried il n'y aura plus rien à
ramasser
avant on pourra plus parler des randos
net c'est joli comme d'importants rando
net merci mélanie les greta ont du
talent c'est le concours organisé chaque
année par
académies d'ile-de-france si hier mardi
ce sont 22 apprentis cuisiniers
pâtissiers qui se sont affrontés au
lycée hôtelier de guyancourt une
véritable battle en quelque sorte en
deux étapes une première partie
d'écriture puis une seconde partie
beaucoup plus technique en cuisine nous
avons suivi les trois candidats
yvelinois fanny bourdillon ingrédients
quantité et recettes
ici on calcule tout et on se prépare à
cuisiner c'est le concours des greta
organisée par les académies de
versailles créteil et paris
cette année la finale a lieu au lycée
hôtelier de guyancourt après l'étape
écrite d'une heure il faut passer en
cuisine et je crois que devant les
fourneaux et en maniant les les
casseroles bien évidemment vous allez
pouvoir vous libérer et justement faire
preuve de tout le talent que l'on attend
de vous merci demandeurs d'emploi ou en
reconversion professionnelle
ils sont 22 stagiaires du réseau des
greta ile de france a tenté leur chance
pour se former dans la restauration
il ya de converser avec lui quelques
années et ça me passionne beaucoup
avant j'étais artiste peintre maintenant
je reste dans les couleurs dans les
matières vous avez trente ans je peux
passer l'examen et du coup ils enfin
c'est une pression la pression naturelle
de l'examen que je sais qu'avec un enjeu
ya rien à perdre rien à gagner
c'est comme ça c'est naturel à peine le
temps de souffler direction les cuisines
pour karim
il doit réaliser deux plats en 3h30 mais
le stress est toujours présent à 3h30
pour faire de plat
après j'aurai un poulet à faire aussi
mais ça va être un petit peu tendu cieux
parce que ces cures 3h30 et puis c'est
pas forcément de maîtrise des techniques
que j'utilise et ottawa
onze candidats concourent à l'épreuve de
cuisine et 11 autres en pâtisserie
fatoumata qui a choisi la pâtisserie
doit réaliser deux desserts dont une
tarte aux pommes mais elle a du mal à
s'organiser
vous avez déjà fait votre choix non pas
encore vous avez passé votre part
l'autre carte non d'accord vous savez
que les preuves de la tarte c'est un
grand challenge pour moi
pour moi finir dans les 3 4
l'objectif avant tout pour ses candidats
se former rapidement pour pouvoir
retrouver un emploi le but c'est quand
même de prendre des gens qui des
personnes comme eux je les dis qu'ils
sont en reconversion
certains qui ont eu des parcours
difficiles il faut quand même le le
reconnaître et notre objectif c'est de
les redynamiser c'est de travailler avec
eux leur projet professionnel est
vraiment de le réinsérer
malgré le stress celle yvelinois karim
terbeche qui a fini premier au concours
de cuisine fatoumata est arrivé
troisième en pâtisserie ils finiront
tous les deux leur ca paix en juin
prochain
gastronomie toujours le centre alfred de
vigny à voisins le bretonneux qui
organisait le week-end dernier la 10e
édition du marché des terroirs durant
deux jours le public était invité à
découvrir ou redécouvrir les produits
des régions française mélanie poquet
patrick jacques de dixmude le cantal la
corse ce week end voisins le bretonneux
jouer la carte du terroir produits du
cru mais pas seulement
au détour d'un étal une madeleine
inspiré par le célèbre ouvrage à la
recherche du temps perdu
cette madeleine vient d'illiers combray
qui est un village qui se situe pas très
loin de chartres en eure et loir là où
aller marcel proust lors de son enfance
il allé chez sa tante léonie déguster
les fameuses manley
et donc notre défi que nous avons relevé
avec ma femme maxime boucher qui a
travaillé aux côtés d'alain passard et
camille l'essec qui était chef pâtissier
d'un grand restaurant parisien 50 hôtels
parisiens
on a décidé de faire une excellente la
laine qui soit à la hauteur de l'oeuvre
de marcel proust et puis une musique
d'un autre temps se faisait entendre
avec les regrattiers d'histoire vous
plonger dans un camp du xvème siècle
c'est un camp ouvert c'est-à-dire qui
permet aux gens de venir à l'intérieur
et d'observer de manipuler
donc on l'est on peut très bien venir
toucher essayer les épées essayer les
casques s'initie un petit peu avec la
cuisine médiévale venir écouter notre
chanteuse et harpiste
le marché du week-end du terroir a fermé
ses portes ce dimanche
en attendant la 11e édition culture
découverte à présent de l'oeuvre de
bertrand flachau des paysage végétal et
urbain entre abstraction et figuration
le photographe plasticien travail en
juxtaposant plusieurs prises de vue une
partie de son travail est à découvrir à
guyancourt jusqu'au 7 mai sephora
nomades urbains ou végétales abstrait ou
figuratif les paysages de bertrand
flachau entrouvre la porte d'un
imaginaire et une volonté de réinventer
le monde en une image complexe et
inédite
diplômé de l'école nationale les arts
décoratifs l'artiste crée des oeuvres à
la frontière de deux expressions
plastiques celle de la photographie est
celle du dessin c'est beaucoup lié à l
intime quand on connaît l'histoire d'un
bertrand clash on se rend compte que
tous ces lieux qui photographie sont des
lieux qui pour lui ont une mémoire qui
ont une histoire
il ya un côté effectivement abstrait
figuratif en même temps donc il ya un
côté où on peut s'évader on peut se
laisser porter par les lignes de
l'artiste ou alors on peut être très
concret en garderont seulement les
paysagés et finalement en faire
abstraction du dessin chacun y voit un
peu ce qui se fait à l'aide d'une
tablette graphique
bertrand flash au sublime ses
photographies numériques
il peut aussi retravailler directement
ses photographies argentiques par le
dessin au crayon une façon d'associer un
instant réel figer un dessin qui peut se
prolonger à l'infini
c'est un artiste qui s'appuie sur des
photographies qu'il prend les mêmes les
photographies de paysages de forêts de
bois mais aussi des photographies de
paris et après ils retravaillent
entièrement sa photographie avec du
dessin mais travaille avec sa tablette
graphique et sa tablette numérique pour
pouvoir sublimer les dessins donc
effectivement on est dans une technique
qui est plutôt original et plutôt actuel
bertrand flachau expose ses
photographies plastiques à la mezzanine
de l'hôtel de ville d'aiguillon court
jusqu'au 7 mai prochain et pour
l'actualité culturelle vous avez rendez
vous dans un instant sur notre antenne
avec le magazine hebdomadaire kiosque
préparer présenté par sephora namani
c'est la fin de ce journal on se
retrouve demain aux horaires habituels
pour un nouveau point complet sur
l'information locale très belle soirée